[Musique]
confinement oblige les activités en
extérieur sont donc réduites il faut à
nouveau s'occuper à la maison et pour
cela aujourd'hui nous vous proposons de
la littérature avec les coups de coeur
de la librairie le pavé du canal à
montigny le bretonneux avec stéphanie
bonjour bonjour vous êtes responsable du
rayon littéraire et vous nous avez a
choisi nature humaine pourquoi
en fait il montre la beauté que peut
être notre planète mais avec toute la
complexité de pouvoir consommer sans
dégâts donc de photos en photo en fait
ils vont montrer que soit le monde marin
le monde terrestre ou tout simplement
l'environnement ce qu'est la nature
aujourd'hui et ce qu'elle risque de
devenir si on ne prend pas conscience de
quelque chose voilà donc pas du tout mon
réalisateur c'est très beau les taxes ni
profond et les les photos sont
absolument extraordinaires avec valéry
responsable du rayon jeunesse bonjour
bonjour vous vous avez un livre de
clémentine bové vous proposer tout à
fait qui s'appelle donc h tendre on est
dans un futur proche on n'est pas dans
une date précise
c'est juste que le stage de 3e dure plus
longtemps que ce que vous n'a
habituellement et notre héros valentin
qui est un garçon introverti qui a
beaucoup de mal avec les changements se
retrouve en fait dans le nord de la
france dont les hauts de france alors
qu'il habite albi dans le sud est qui va
se retrouver dans un ehpad est en fait
dans son rapport de stage c'est ce que
nous allons lire en fête à l'intérieur
il va raconter ce qu'ils voient ce qui
connaît
[Musique]
avec pauline vous êtes la directrice de
la librairie le pavé du canal bonjour
bonjour et avec vous on va parler egypte
ancienne
oui tout à fait à travers un
documentaire qui s'adresse aux 8 9 ans
c'est à la fois un documentaire donc
avec des informations historiques très
simple qui résume bien les sujets
abordés voilà c'est par thème et vous
avez une petite boîte un coffre aux
trésors qui contient un masque funéraire
à fabriquer des pyramides l'enfant à
pouvoir aussi apprendre à écrire en
héros de lift est un jeu traditionnel
égyptien
merci pour cette proposition je vous en
prie et on le rappelle même si les
livres ne sont pas considérés comme
essentiels ils sont toujours disponibles
en cliquant collecte le principe est
simple vous commander sur internet et
puis vous pouvez venir les chercher sur
place ou les faire livrer directement
chez vous